okay hello to everyone on the live
stream we are continuing and hopefully
concluding a review of mentioned audio
processing for the upcoming version
Wolff language okay well we got to last
time I think at the end of audio so if
you scroll down to audio okay yep we
have not finished some of these okay so
but we got stuck on the voice styles
business and we talked about some of the
this yes we talked about these okay the
annotation stuff we broke off into a
separate meeting and we have not quite
concluded that right right so I'm not
quite sure what we do with that as it is
there I'm I'm not confident of that
design I think we will have to I think
we were making good progress on thinking
about annotations in general but I think
we need to use that progress to figure
this out
I don't even know and we do a one pass
through Stephen and then return to that
if you want more time in that general
discussion before we come back here yeah
I think we should do that I mean I think
also this is a one shot you know it's
basically wrapped this audio so in
metadata like an annotation presumably
so that it can be plugged in to other
audio and joined together other is that
correct yeah so there are many legs to
this so first thing is like to keep it
around and to make it not separate from
the object then you can build players
and then you can do
yeah but look at the specification here
this is a whole audio tagging right yeah
this is this is a high-level function
that allows to add annotations it's
allowing you to add annotations are only
in a particular way it's only whole
audio metadata annotation it is not
subong notation within an audio no it's
sub annotations it's not look at the
specification well you look at spec what
is spec go down it's time or a time
interval a various ways oh gosh okay all
right okay okay okay all right this is
I'm convinced this is the wrong way
around I'm convinced that it should be x
goes to her other labels I see what you
have in mind here is that there are only
particular attributes like audible
inaudible that you're tagging could we
please whoever is making background
noise could you please adjust things so
you don't do that um they um okay that
case now what was that again come on
okay so you you understand you you're
looking at a small number of attributes
that you are tagging for which I don't
think is what we imagine is the future I
don't know I think that it's it's more
likely to be just one and and more no no
it's going to be Baba's talking bill is
talking Jane is talking and that sounds
like the same attribute which speaker
know but that's not what you're doing
here what you just saying is you look
what I'm saying is what should be
happening is you're specifying the
location and then you're specifying what
to say about that location
it's a open-ended well whatever
I mean look there - it's open-ended the
value is open-ended which value what
what the property is that you want to
store at that event or that interval and
at all this time this is a way of
annotating objects value is the one that
can set any annotation any label any way
you that you want yeah those prop think
Steven they are things that
automatically creates annotations from
computations okay okay so that's not the
general case those are just things that
are currently automatically available
and that will be listen we have to come
back to this okay sure actually have
Carlo in that discussion you know I
already request that that that he gets
added to the next meeting all right
great Oh Carlo has been working on audio
oh okay yeah okay I mean this is
important and we need to sort it out but
we just need to iterate through the
other discussion of annotations sure
okay great okay I don't really know what
this is what is this it's Fourier
transforms for basically blocks of time
you know so you can see normally a
Fourier transform assumes stationarity
right and most else on that stage like
in a spectrogram we had spectrogram
array but then that didn't keep any
information about the computation no
parameters that's right so we couldn't
umber that now this one is retaining
aspect short time for you tape the
object that stores all the properties
okay that seems very ornate I mean how
do I turn that into something more
everyday
how do I do something with that we do
have those functions audio spectral map
all your spectral transform I believe
those are the ones that every day you
may want to use okay but if I just say
normal of this to turn into anything or
is it still some random thing that's
just but you can give it a short time
Fourier data what would I do with this I
don't understand I mean because Fourier
also could have something which
maintains scale and all that kind of
stuff well but it's more important here
than its Fourier why because you need to
know the length of the blocks among
other things okay so what can I actually
do with it how do I use it
the applications
if I take the output right other than
making a spectrogram out of it can I
convolve it with some thing or what mmm
be able to involve it I mean if it was
just a list I would be able to control
vit yeah but it isn't just a list what
does it have in it in addition to being
a list it's it's multiple for your
transforms basically and it really needs
it's very own weirdo structure well you
wanted to be able to invert it right
you've asked for inverse spectrogram a
couple of times right and this
implements the inverse inverse
spectrogram is for the purpose of taking
a no no let's be clear about what that
is it's something like you have an image
and you want to certify the image by
considering the image as a spectrogram
okay and that's exactly how this project
and the three symbols this is the right
way to solve that problem because I mean
what we want okay so let's imagine okay
we do an audio capture I hope this isn't
gonna crash oh great hello hello hello
I think it's crashing whatever okay so I
I'll be able to do this okay so the
thing I'm trying to understand let's
just take an ordinary spy program here
hello
okay now first of all what is the
spectrogram graphics
that's pure graphics okay so can I get
the image out of this how do I get so
spectrogram array of percent 48 will
produce what more normal thing yeah the
data okay so if I say array plot of ABS
of this is that what is that you got the
transpose of the spectrogram and then
twice of that right so spectrogram it's
getting rid of the redundant information
because this is because it's redundant
in the because of sampling kind of stuff
Roger by the way I'm pretty sure you're
making that noise
the okay so if I wanted to do an inverse
Petra Graham array that is going from
because I mean the thing that I think is
going to be relevant is you're trying to
make a sound from you know but basically
from something which you've generated
from I don't know some random process
it's machine learning I don't know what
it's a it's a Sun sonification mechanism
right
like you say I know what the spectrogram
should look like okay so I want to know
how what is the way to do that and why
can't I do it
so with this Fourier transform things
what are you saying should happen is
there an inverse short time for a yes
it's the point yeah I just understand
this crazy object that comes out okay by
the way we don't typically have dashes
in these situations to wait okay so
let's go look at that object again okay
to see what it has in it and you I was
saying it is a collection I mean I just
think the threshold for creating a whole
nother head a whole nother object should
be really high okay so I thought any
argument does it need to be fully
qualified the inverse operation for
reconstruction missing I'm sorry I'm
okay yeah sorry sorry how many extra
arguments does it need to be fully
qualified for an inverse operation in
order to do it completely correct we
need all of them number three there's
three more arguments that you need to
supply in order to get fully you know
right I mean so here okay so we've got
some extra
stuff here right right so at the minimum
you need partition size officer then
this moving window and then if you don't
have proper padding and stuff you may
get some misalignment on the boundaries
but not in that you know that's not as
big of a deal but without partition size
officer then smoothing when those things
are going to be back excu okay so this
is this is in order to be able to get
back out the the correct correct
frequency and all that kind of thing
right okay so you get a waveform which
is not a frequency yes so I understand
so but so this data here is the analog
of this data here is that correct is
that a spectrum am i right yes is it
exactly the spectrogram array
I mean if I say spectrogram array Trippi
yes and data extracted from the short by
48 data no I'm not going to do that I'm
gonna do this is it that I know what the
4 is does seem to be the same thing yep
okay what is that for
that's the partition size okay
it is the smoothing window
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
so the may bless you here is you know
some of the time you know what those
parameters are has just created them in
spectrogram array I'm a making sense yes
so you know there's also automatic so
you you know know there's a one org form
of it where everything is automatic no I
understand so I don't understand why we
don't have spectrogram by an inverse
spectrogram array which has the exact
same defaults a spectrogram array and in
the case of spectrogram array you can
give this argument perhaps as an
association rather blah blah blah you
pick up that Association and you put it
back again in into a spectrogram array
though it's if you don't know the case
that I think is most common is you're
trying to sana Phi some random piece of
data you don't intrinsically know what
those parameters should be you have to
make them up they didn't come from
anywhere
am I making sense yes which means that
this weird head is going to do you no
good I think I mean convinced me
otherwise but I think the correct thing
is to have an inverse spectrogram array
that simply returns an audio object well
what is it getting data from it lists
but again that's another thing that gets
stored and their data object now okay
but that's a-ok because it's not going
to be the useful thing because the
useful thing is you've given essentially
an image or an array here and you're
told reconstruct typically
audio from that array well it's got to
know that yes that those those you know
things in the array correspond to
frequencies you know two thousand Hertz
or whatever else and that's presumably
in your package in the package right but
remember you didn't get the data from
doing short time Fourier transform you
got the data from some random machine
learning process or some random thing
where you've got you know where these
are ripples on the surface of a lake on
Mars or something right they didn't come
from doing transform from an audio
object they we are trying to create an
audio object from them making sense now
maybe that's the wrong construct maybe
the right construct well I don't know
what what I mean the typical kick they
says you've got a picture like this and
I want to sana Phi it I'm making sense I
mean I suppose there could be a function
called spectrogram audio and what it
would do is take the spectrogram
represented as or even spectrogram array
audio what do you expect us to get that
graphics parse out the 5000 and I do not
expect the graphic I expect the
spectrogram yes okay remember the array
didn't come from audio you understand
what I'm saying yeah the array came from
somewhere else
so you know what I'm saying is if I give
you
so that's doable Steven I think it will
have a lot of user faith your cases
because the parameters are not correct
the reconstruction is going to be
incorrect okay let's figure out how to
make it better I mean that what the user
is because I agree they're not gonna
have complex numbers there they're gonna
be a lot of crazy things but the typical
thing somebody wants to do okay here's
the case that I'm imagining you see that
picture and you say I want to stun fi
that are you getting what I'm saying yes
okay so what's the best way to do that
this is I in chair they send you an
example without this from marketing
version 10 okay I mean this is what I
have in mind I mean I assume yeah
exactly
this is what I have in mind so what's
the best packaging for this I mean I
don't think you know I don't know
whether whatever short time Fourier
transform is it may be useful function
its own right but it should be a list to
list function so to speak right it
shouldn't be something that generates
some weird head Oh enlisted yes list to
lists just like Fourier but then there
would be just a spectrogram array we can
be named that if you want no no okay so
what about the inverse well the inverse
we could write sort of invar
spectra camera but it will require the
specific arguments no but they're all
going to default if you say spectrogram
array of something and it's likely to be
a high failure rate no no wait a second
wait a second wait a second it defaulted
to something inverse spectrogram array
can use the same defaults correct or not
correct obviously it can you know so
then why will it fail because you said
it doesn't come from there right it
doesn't use this understand that I
understand that so inverse spectrogram
array is solving the problem of taking a
spectrogram array and being able to
invert it I don't think we can have this
defaults we're looking at the length of
the input to compute what should be the
default and the partition size and
overlap and the window function is
always a fixed window you may actually
get a 10 by 10 result back for different
lengths of audio depending on the
automatic values used for computing the
spectrogram then the spectrogram array
is not going to be very useful for
anything if you can't know what it's
making it's not going to be very useful
I mean the main use is making a picture
which is what spectrogram does how would
you what would you do with spectrogram
alright what's the point of spectrogram
array it's a day
version of that picture okay but its
primary role here is to be picture of
all because it's actual raw data you say
is kind of incomprehensible
what have you used spectrogram array for
you can still compute on it right you
can't not if you don't know what it's
pieces are you're actually right because
we have to keep track of how many
samples in time as the x-axis or the
columns represent and what's the
partitioning of frequency so what would
we expect to do with a spectrogram I
mean you get smooth spectrogram we could
you know do a band pass on a spectrogram
we could do all kinds of things on a
spectrogram mm-hm I mean we could have a
spectrogram object which you know for
all we know oh this thing here could be
a spectrogram object rather than a piece
to graphics just formatting as a piece
of graphics and we could operate on that
spectrogram object with you know
bandpass filters and God knows what else
and that me seems quite reasonable and
we just thought this the name
spectrogram is wrong because that that's
typically referring to the plot anyways
I understand but if spectrogram produce
there's a spectrogram object or
something that displays as the plot that
should work yeah I mean if there's an
object then you can store that meta
information around what I'm saying yeah
that's what I'm saying so I'm saying so
you're just saying roughly the same
thing but with a sort of an altar
display kind of feature that's what I'm
suggest
so I'm suggesting two things okay that
spectrogram produces a spectrogram
object which also displays in that form
that functions like band pass filter
work on spectrogram objects is that
plausible or is that not plausible yeah
I mean is that a sensible idea or not
seems that and support to me yeah okay
so like filters should just work on the
spectrogram object so you can see the
effect of a filter directly on the
spectrogram seems worthwhile to me
mm-hmm and then the only other issue is
how do you get audio back from the
spectrogram object well they're two
other issues how do you get audio from
the spectrogram object and arguably you
should just put wrap audio all around
the spectrogram object and it should
just work that make sense
you guys here yeah yeah did that make
sense to you and then how do we go back
to the list version if spectrogram was
coming from a list
wait wait wait we'll wait wait wait wait
so so this okay so there is a final
issue here okay which is how to go from
a list to represent to make that list
correspond to a spectrogram okay and as
you say a naked list you don't have any
idea how to map that to a spectrogram
right no more you have little no more
idea how to map that to a spectrogram as
you have an idea how to map a naked
lists turn to an image for example
there's all
stuff about about you know you know what
are the image dimensions what's the
color map thing all those kinds of stuff
mm-hmm okay but we have the same issue
here of how do we take the raw
spectrogram pixels effective way and
render them as most often we'd want to
render them as a sound am I making sense
did I make sense there but again you
need there's no but the fundamental
thing you're trying to do there look the
fundamental function there I would have
thought would be something like you know
spectrogram audio of a list of data okay
that tries to do something reasonable
and doesn't put it into you know
ultrasound or infrasound and just tries
to do something reasonable with it but
then can be given all kinds of
parameters that say exactly how the
thing should be lined up in in you know
frequency space etcetera since so I mean
the goal spectrogram audio and one thing
I don't know is the phase information
what happens if you just stripped the
phase information that Griffin them
algorithm tries to estimate it okay okay
fine so so then even somebody who has
essentially a black-and-white picture
could use it as a spectrogram okay we
should
see if it works I mean this is my
suggestion for how this should be
designed comments Roger
we tried I think we can get me give it
another try we didn't could do quite
like this what you propose but close so
that's gonna try and the main worry I
have is the number of failure cases is
gonna generate in the automatic case it
switch automatic case you know when you
don't give the parameters which
automatic case we'll be talking about
spectra crap
I'm audio is talking about something
different and spectrum when it tries to
get audio from spectrogram okay but okay
but listen we have a lot of control over
what's happening there we've been given
the day right and you know what do you
think the failure cases will be you
don't hear anything it okay I can't
remember now but this is exactly where
we went through them why we constructed
this because I think failure rate I
agree where if you've got a naked array
it is not enough to faithfully
reconstruct the sound it came from but
I'm not proposing that I'm proposing
that this is something where were you -
if you had a spectrogram here I mean
what you're kind of proposing is roughly
the same idea but with slightly read
jiggering
of the order fine okay let's give it a
whirl see what happens yeah okay let's
move on that we can scan
we've already that's another meeting we
had okay all right
this looks like a very complicated set
of issues is it not you agree yeah I
don't think so it's you've already same
see me prove this almost in there in the
earth stage yeah you do how do I feed it
- what happens if I feed in America
right to a list plot so this is this is
various issues like how far does it work
and this can be there's there's much
more to be done on that it's been mainly
a container at this point you don't want
to give sample values here for you to
give solver values over for you once I
have that about the fold
oh my god either I had talked to you
about this we have gone back and forth
on the typesetting a couple of times why
I mean what I would have done here if I
could have gotten this you know is to
say 1 2 3 4 5 about paren 100 elements
but maybe that's not right
I mean if I if I have a two dimensional
numeric array makes it gets very
complicated
okay I don't even understand what that
data means that we can start putting
curly braces before the 99 and the other
iteration on that but then what if you
really have you know a 50 dimensional
array and all you see is just three
heuristics okay but you shouldn't have
it so that it's really hard to
understand even in the one-dimensional
array case okay now what is this going
to do if I say so if I were to say they
on on percent for I was to say let's
plot percent for okay but let's plot
normal a percent for will just work
under that system wide support store
Donald cloud that shows you our plan for
having the system wide support for well
so I mean you're saying you've got some
pieces of this but there's more coming
later oh yeah okay but these are the
ones that exist today yes okay and this
plugs directly into the compiler yes
eventually yes what was the eventually I
don't think it was a eventually I
thought it was already happening now
it's you mean yeah
we don't have it
yes what do you mean so so hold on
second I thought numeric array was
something that was being created so that
the compiler would have a datatype to
exchange numeric array of data with is
that not correct no it's not correct oh
gosh it the main the main people that
want this is the machine learning folk
and image signal processing folk okay
what is the status of communicating it
with library link or the compiler we
have library link we have a numeric
array construct for library link and
that's also being a little document that
we had it be drawn right before and we
had all of that supported and used in
our old library link packets and so
forth and now we're giving it documented
numeric array this could should should
directly go into the compiler well there
is there is things coming from the
runtime library to support this okay
that's entirely relevant yeah but he
doesn't know they didn't get created by
the compiler people at all they haven't
been driving this no I know that I know
that but I thought it was being created
so that it could be it could become
because when you have a type thing and
the compiler is the difference between
to become no I thought when you have
okay something like this right what is
the type specification for an America
for an integer 64 yeah and that's
probably correct I just don't know what
states the compiler is at no but you're
saying what I'm trying to understand is
there is a way of there is some type of
specification which corresponds to an
America right and
it's unified okay okay so there is the
same yes just saying okay good but but
from there to you your leap of saying
that operations work on it there
probably his son but I don't know what
state it's in Oh fine fine
well hopefully we can determine that um
okay fair enough
all right fair enough okay let's keep
going here
what's byte array format it's like five
format for spring formal working on bike
race okay alright so that's what year I
was working on was that right I don't
think so I'm sorry there's a different
I'm sorry different project no you you
you're right there was a person the
summer school or summer camp this year
who wrote who did a machine learning
thing to try and answer this question
about what format a byte array is in
because one way to do it is with the
magic numbers of the beginning of the
byte array correct
sure the other way to do it what I'm
sorry
like for files yes but the other way to
do it is to look at content right sure
and the surprising fact from this
person's project was that it was very
easy to get with very very very high
probably let's say even if you're in the
middle of a file to figure out what
format is making sense yeah this doesn't
include any of them this is should add
functionality be be more
fully developed and be part of file
format I would think so I would think so
I mean because the original project was
extracting strings out of byte arrays
okay which which needs to happen right
am I making sense of who is maintaining
by to write at this point I don't know
okay we gonna find that out right
I thought piatto was dealing with byte
array not quite no we have done a few
things on top of the original by the
rate development but it's it's really
not that pure is maintained yeah well I
mean there's some fairly straight
forward stuff to be done with byte
arrays um I think that's
discussion but it's something that we
should get the basic byte array
operations to be done and I don't know
whether you have folks who could work on
that I don't think it's particularly
difficult comments on that
do you have pieces of it right if I look
at the big nuts or the fullness yeah
I've got I've got a list this is
apparently a community post I'm quite
sure what this is okay so this is this
project basically mm-hmm and that
project has github sand everything look
in terms of byte arrays yeah absolutely
I need to go in a minute but I
absolutely have okay let me look here I
have a bunch of there we go that's 2014
this is about base encoding which I
think we do have okay so this says a
bunch of the operations for byte array
byte array plot those kinds of things
right
would you like take this file check I
think there's a good starter project for
somebody really independent of
everything else and it's some you know
very well defined
well this is orphan 2015 yeah I think
this is the best summary the thing
that's here okay anything else we should
make sure to look at here okay should I
look at the import new page five cards
as well yeah this one is well important
you export you what's new these I think
old pages were not really readable and
in some parts they were incorrect okay
so what you can bring up the other ones
labor side if you want okay so I guess
main thing some structure in there so
that the input part what can that be
that's the very stable then the fact
that we were having format specified the
way we were documenting it before format
comma element then not all the other
specified elements for exactly as as we
had documented know for so I split and
then eventually those many notes about
options are going to be cleaned up so
that we say what are the general import
formats import options things like path
and all the server authentication
medication stuff is really pretty
important yes
okay okay I had a section that said what
are the things that we have completely
removed if you want to look at it and if
you have any objections in the exclude
not excluded part at the end of the
notes last four notes those are the ones
that note about compression they just
leave the m4 gzip and France
I agree things like there's no point in
doing that every every import we don't
need to say that back on that's crazy
it's like we really want to push people
to individual format pages from having
is from examples thinking to as many
format pages as we can like use proposal
on their scope says you know for all
your sense to the most important all
your format that's so for me I think
that's great yes I fully support this
how are we doing on so these things are
more or less done that's that right
adding a lot framework level support for
partial access and then you probably
remember that some file formats like
JPEG TIFF started having take elements
take rows and the things like that as
import options now we are implementing
all of those as the sub-elements
specification and that's becoming very
consistent across the board so some some
utilities and function functionalities
in the framework is coming and then some
speed improvement all over
looks reasonable to me it looks useful
great
don't forget come on don't forget here
that it should have file system map and
things like that should be links from
that and fascist file system scan is
probably more useful than file system
map okay this this some RLE thing what
is its length encoding is that right yes
it's use particular why's it so slow I'm
just
putting this okay so what's the point
here
I mean sorry we're just keeping it
experimental we have discussed that
before no but but I mean the thing is
that this thing is used for like
cellular automata and configurations
right and there is an early format which
has the rule for run-length encoding
string and then there is a part that has
certain metadata correction yes okay so
are you saying that you have you are
dealing with the string which were not
dealing with the metadata or what's the
story different format so virally we
just don't even support some-some format
so they for the ones like we do support
Galli and for that we can import
metadata as well why don't you call it
go away format because nobody's gonna
understand that it's orally early it's
just the core of it it's just how to
import like a picture like this it's a
it's a look honestly in modern times it
would have been some other lossless
compression scheme Arlie is it's just a
very old-fashioned lossless compression
scheme mmm makes sense so that's just
the core the full thing should be and
somebody like EDA should be able to
build it they the core of it this is the
core of a gali importer and the goalie
importer by default should produce some
cellular automaton object not a string
or an image making sense interesting
okay well the the
coold underneath there orally pour this
from it and that has some limitation
since both speed and tomaten type object
coming back what would that be
something like the rule numbers and the
rule you should be able to get the
configuration right and we've got nice
ways to specify both of those and
they're both in the Gauley specification
which i want to emphasize again is not
RLE the core piece that is the
configuration is ronk encoded the rest
of it is just some random you know key
value type format does that make sense
I'm decoding the key value format is
what is the extra value here right okay
this is decoding a pure orally yes which
is nothing to do with solar Tantra you
can have orally things you know for
anything
yep right as it says for astra mention
format yes nothing but the gulley files
are specifically files that are full of
of you know metadata that includes the
solar or Thomason rule to use blah blah
blah okay so I think we need to add the
Gauley file for me that's what I like
the what it should return I'm you know
the thing that I'm thinking about is
really
there's the rule and there's the initial
condition mm-hmm
there may be the whole thing there may
be the wholesaler automaton construct
which means there should be a we're
returning that as a held expression for
example you have to look at it I don't
remember what they have in it I know
they have rule specifications they may
also have number of time steps worst
locations mm-hmm okay which means that
will be a whole you know as I say held
object right but definitely the thing
that should happen is there should be
import elements for dolly that
correspond into the rule the initial
condition fair enough okay anything else
here
one other thing to get your approval for
all right target option for export
reasonable you saw there don't we have
some other things for all kinds of other
stuff don't we have this forum for the
file exactly so now I did framework yes
I agree that that override target should
be an option to export okay as well as
to I mean there are the functions that
create files for which this should also
be I thought that was an option like
this also have they say speech for this
speech synthesize an audio capture and
so forth why they do also return all
your files and then if the file exists
at the same location okay but but I was
gonna say what about here this is
[ __ ] I mean as if I might say so the
stuffing there come on this is this is
about this is nothing to do with this
right okay
examples is really kind of shocking here
but the thing that I'm thinking about is
where else are there cases where we need
essentially overwrite I thought there
were file operations that there were
functions that did this for files
they're not this are you thinking about
file system map scan again there was a
file system transform that we design I
never got implemented no that's what
file system at that one doesn't produce
new files that these necessarily yeah
okay fair enough right yeah file system
transform was going to be what else was
there there was something else that has
an operation like this
I think there's some issue with this
also that has the same I know that's
other can you send out mail to people
because I'm pretty sure there are the
functions that are supposed to be using
this or are using this and what do you
want me to say
you want to know no I want to know
whether there are I think there is
another way of doing this that has
another neck I see okay okay
and that's what I'm trying to find okay
Roger I don't know what you're doing
it's driving me completely bonkers but
whatever this background noise is it's
just sorry okay I don't know what any of
those mean for hdf5
complex keys when we are exporting and
so hdf5 doesn't support a complex type
when we're exporting it's storing it as
a compound data set so what keys to use
to refer to real and imaginary and when
importing what keys to assume are
representing complex values and then
hdf5 already had an append function that
was a boolean append option there was a
boolean option there pen mode now he's
getting string settings okay seems
reasonable
you know export designs for hdf5 and
fits are not easy so we may come back to
it once so we have things a little bit
more settled okay well lots of great
stuff all right
so we have to loop back on the
annotation stuff and on the spectrogram
audio spectrogram business
um there were a few names you didn't
like as well like color neighborhood you
did a lot like image pyramid apply you
didn't like any nowhere until you were
going to meet with philip under the
design who supports it i guess really
the only thing remaining is whether we
call image parameter ploy what it is now
or maybe image problem I don't we're not
gonna do that right now okay we need yet
another meeting I think what why don't
we come back with we've got several
follow-ups here we've got the voice
styles business we've got the image
pyramid business the annotation business
we don't have to have them all solved
you know a few of these on their own are
going to take us so now so let's
you know we're continuing to iterate but
this is good stuff and um yeah okay I
gotta run okay see you guys later